لذا ، عاد الرعاة الألمان للرئيس بايدن هذا الصباح إلى ولاية
ديلاوير ، حيث
أخبرت مصادر CNN أن الكلاب أزيلت
من البيت الأبيض أمس
بعد حادثة عض شملت أحد
أفراد فريق الأمن.
أبلغت كيت بينيت وكيت بينيت من شركة سي إن إن هذه
أنها تعيش في واشنطن مع
المزيد ، لذا ما حدث كيت
لذا أليسون أوه ميجور كلب أصغر
يبلغ من العمر حوالي ثلاث سنوات ولأني
أريد أن أقول
إنني كلب ، فهذه بيئة جديدة
بالنسبة للكلاب ، نعلم أن الكلاب
تتصرف
، قد يكون الأمر مخيفًا ، أنا متأكد من أن أكون في
البيت الأبيض
مع أشخاص جدد ، وجوه جديدة ، الأمن ،
كل أنواع الأشياء ، لكن
كانت هناك حادثة مع
عض عضو في فريق الأمن لدي
تحدث إلى
عدد قليل من الأشخاص الذين قالوا إن الرائد هو أم
أنت تعرف قليلاً على الجانب الوحشي أنه
نباح أنه معروف بأنه يتهم
بأنه
يشعر ببعض الاضطراب بين
بطل الكلبين الذي كان أكبر سناً بكثير في 13 عامًا
تقريبًا  آذان
قديمة ولديه مشاكل في التنقل في
هذه المرحلة ، لكن
المشكلة الرئيسية هي المشكلة التي كانت تمثل مشكلة في البيت الأبيض
منذ انتقالهم في نهاية شهر
يناير ،
فأنت تعلم أن السيدة الأولى د.
استقرت الكلاب كانت الأولوية رقم واحد
أم تأكد من هدوء الجميع
واه أنت تعلم ألا تقفز على
الأثاث كله قالت لكيلي كلاركسون
في برنامجها الحواري أه ولكن بجدية هذه
مشكلة عندما يكون لديك كلب أه
لديك عدة  أفراد طاقم
الخدمة السرية
أه عمال الصيانة وأنت تعرف
فقط عامة الناس والصحافة هذه
كلاب معتادة على
نوع معين من الحياة ونقلهم
إلى البيت الأبيض
كان بالتأكيد تغييرًا في
بيئتهم آه العودة إلى ديلاوير أنا
لا أعتقد أن أي شخص يجب أن ينظر إليه على أنه
عقاب ، لكنه بالتأكيد
يساعد الآن في تخفيف المشكلة
بشكل جيد ، فمن المؤكد أنه يبدو أن الرئيس
بايدن سيفتقد الكلاب ،
أعني أن الكلاب محددة  جزء من
عائلة بايدن الذي أشار إليه أنه حصل على
بطل قبل أن يصبح نائبًا
للرئيس في عهد الرئيس
أوباما كان كلب إنقاذ
أه من مأوى في ديلاوير إنه أول
كلب مأوى يعيش في البيت الأبيض
أه في تاريخ البيت الأبيض لذا
بالتأكيد أه نتمنى أن نراهم
قريبًا لكن لا يوجد الآن ما يشير إلى أنهم سيعودون
إلى البيت الأبيض